thank you for being here this afternoon
[Music]
and along with my colleague hazel Harvey
we are cold conveners of this Frankie
seminar on race and cast so it is my
very very great pleasure to introduce
professor rau today professor row is
tell associate professor of history at
Barnard College in Columbia University
she received her PhD from the
interdepartmental program in
anthropology and history at the
University of Michigan which she is also
an acting director of the Institute for
comparative literature and society and
organizer of the annual Ambedkar
lectures at Barnard and Columbia
professor Rao has written widely on the
themes of colonialism and
humanitarianism and our non-western
histories of gender and sexuality her
book the caste question theorized caste
and Buddhism with specific focus on the
history of antique a spot and its
thinkers and producing alternative
genealogies of political subject
formation she's written numerous other
essays she's edited several volumes on
the topic of caste and valid history as
well but in in general I would say her
work is remarkable from the way that she
thinks about producing the history of
the Dalit public sphere and thinking
about the late intellectual history and
her work has become really seminal in
any understanding of that history of the
late thinking in India the caste
question engages with Dalit emancipation
and new forms of power and subjection
that appear in colonial and postcolonial
India and in her book the caste question
which is an amazing and wonderful book
she takes us from British colonial
governance to the back
of the contemporary reservation system
in post-colonial India she tracks
through Dalit intellectual thought and
activism how bureaucratic responses
produce different ways to think the
political subjectivity of Dalits and she
looks particularly at questions of
violence and of subjection right
thinking of what violence is unspeakable
or indecipherable such violence she
argues in that book are characteristic
of the making of Dalit subjectivities in
shifting ways subjectivities that are
both dignitize and revolutionary and
she's at work
following that amazing brilliant book
and all of the editorial work she's been
doing on three other projects are be
more more a sure Memoirs of a Dalit
communist another entitled on bed gun in
his time in ours and a third on Ballack
bombay stigma precarity and everyday
life we're delighted to have her with us
today her talk is entitled historical
comparison social abstraction thinking
cost race gender in the time of capital
please join me in welcoming professor
Rob thank you so very much I'm really
thrilled to be here I please give me
just a second and then I'll start
talking but I also just want to I have
this up on a loop and so this will go
around a few times as I said this is an
on the first slide is necessary it gives
you a sense of the the shape of their
talk that I'm going to give but the rest
of the slides are images for
entertainment
they are disaggregated from my talk so
you can view them they will come around
a few times they're connected and
they're interlinked to what I'll be
saying but they're not absolutely
essential that is to say I'm not using
the slides to make an argument that is
connected to the to the talk that I'll
be reading so with that said it's really
a great great pleasure for me to be here
and I'd like to thank
hazal carbon in their Palgrave all
fellow travelers and pathfinders for
inviting me thanks also to the Whitney
Humanities Center and to the Frankie
family for making these engagements in
public humanities possible the semester
long exploration of caste and race I
understand is engaged or interested in
thinking through the peculiar affinities
the missed meetings and the awkward
correspondences between caste and race
each a peculiar agent of transformation
each offering a way to think the human
indifference and each predicating the
imagination of equality on rethinking
the relationship between embodiment and
the universal as I thought about my
presentation today it seemed apt to try
to exemplify a method that thinks about
the problem of comparison of equivalents
and commence raishin across analytic
levels and to do so by thinking the
supplementarity of caste and race the
one calling up the other has obtained
brace a forgotten twin this is what I'm
going to present is a little
experimental because I'm going to be
choosing some sites for conversation and
hopefully we can link them together in
the in our Q&A but I want to begin with
my own personal history of moving from
Bangalore to Chicago's South Side as a
point of entry into broader questions
about historical comparison questions of
space colonial capital and how the
social abstractions of capital enabled
an insurgent globality one that was
predicated on the right to think and
imagine a new including connections
across race and caste I adopt this mode
of disjuncture areeda ng of reading
across specific histories of destitution
deprivation and remaking to give you a
sense of time place and a problem at
hand I hope you'll witness something
like an instantiation of this method as
I said of disjunctive comparison along
the way I said I was going to begin with
personal but with personal history but
of course we know that our autobiography
is never quite what we think it is
recall Dubois as dusk of dawn published
in 1940 with a subtitle autobiography of
a race concept which uses the self as an
example for broader
on being an unthinking or the fact that
the other person that I will focus on
somewhat stood a br ambedkar resisted
the self-exposure preferred by his
intimate egg on MK Gandhi and who outed
himself only episodically and one might
say in his marginal writings so my talk
today is going to be framed around two
broad questions or problematics one is
to think about the question of world is
to think about the world made anew in
the context of the late 19th century and
the transformations and the
reorientation of global capital in that
moment and then I wanted to relate that
to the question of thought this first
section is called inhabitation connected
worlds I was conducting historical
research on Bombay it's about their
neighborhoods and the question of social
housing that is I was thinking about
Bombay as a paradoxical site for the
experience of social emancipation and a
catalyst for new forms of out casting
and exclusion when I partner and I
decided to buy an apartment in New York
some years ago like everyone who buys
property in New York City we found
ourselves negotiating a maze of legal
regulations that elaborated a
fundamental contradiction between
viewing one's home as an economic asset
on the one hand and viewing housing or
the home a shelter or refuge on the
other the process of making home was
pleasurable but it was also fraud it
brought back vivid memories of the home
I'd left behind in 1979 when my family
moved from India to the United States
that house in Bangalore occupied a large
corner plot it was designed by my
England returned engineer father with a
taste for natural ventilation and
quality materials
I remember the polished teak and
rosewood inside as I do the coke as I do
the coconut pomegranate and guava trees
of doors but most of all I'm reminded
now that this was a South Indian Brahmin
home it's secular modernity cohabiting
quite easily with signs of caste I
arrived in Chicago when I was 10 and for
the next decade it was the geography of
the city's south side that organized my
world this was the world of the Prairie
shores and Lake Meadows high rises along
Lakeshore Drive
the one stately homes now burned out or
boarded up along Indiana Avenue as one
made once way into Hyde Park and the one
way streets and brownstones that
surrounded the University of Chicago
where I'd gone to school and where there
was always talk in hushed tones about
no-go areas like the Midway Plaisance it
was as of the city's segregated history
index too deep violence that could
incapacitate thought unless we could
keep it at arm's length
and so we did many of us embrace
European thought and theory in the
process we forgot that the University of
Chicago was the birthplace of urban
sociology the famous Chicago School and
the cast school with race relations the
Chicago schools focused on the city as a
social laboratory had produced a number
of fine-grained studies of unions race
relations housing transport and much
else
however the university's own efforts of
social engineering was rarely
acknowledged although evidence of its
destruction of a once thriving
african-american neighborhood was all
around us my memories of Bangalore only
makes sense when placed against the
contrasting experience of Chicago's
South Side much of the story if a real
estate acquisition in New York called to
mind ongoing research on housing in
Bombay it's as if the cross-referencing
of historical geographies and personal
itinerary not to mention the apparent
convergence between historically
distinct and logically disjoint spatial
processes constituted a mode of critical
reading it's a mode of reading that sees
comparison is both politically necessary
and methodologically insufficient such
reading is insufficient because
comparison always introduces the idea of
a developmental norm against which
objects are compared yet comparison also
enhances political perception when we
compare X with Y we're also asking how X
was produced why X appears to be lacking
when it's compared with Y or how it is
that x and y though they are different
appear to have been produced by similar
processes historical comparison is
vice-versa what links India to the
United States what links Chicago and
Bombay
is it possible to trace moments of
historical convergence when the two
spaces came to be constituted by similar
social forces and economic processes the
restructuring of the colonial economy
was one such moment when loss of British
access to American cotton spurred the
growth of Bombay is an important
Imperial hub that developed around the
cotton economy and linked the city with
its hinterland through new technologies
of travel labor migration and
environmental transformation chicago's
rise as a modern city was enabled by the
Fire of 1871 which had created a rare
opportunity for urban zoning on modern
planning as in Bombay's bubonic plague
of 1896 these connections are
conjuncture but the consequences are
visible and long-lasting in the
aftermath of their natural disasters
both Chicago and bombay came to be
associated with forms of stigmatized
housing the ghetto and the slum
respectively which instantiate broader
processes of labour mobilization and
which regulated social difference
through this through the segregation of
space the political geographer David
Harvey suggests that the modern city is
a space of political pacification where
urban dispossession has been
accomplished through what he calls
repeated bouts of urban restructuring
through creative destruction and that
this is a process that almost always has
a class dimension since it's the poor
the underprivileged and the marginalized
who suffer first and foremost from this
process we can argue it seems to me that
these urban revolutions are racializing
processes as well as they surely are you
know well the mass migration of African
Americans from Mississippi and the
Carolinas to urban centers in the
Midwest and the Northeast of 1.5 million
migrated in the period between 1910 and
1930 a further three million had
migrated from 1940 to 1960 leading to a
scarcity of housing in northern cities
the legislature the legislated right to
property ownership was secured via
practice
of redlining and racial covenant in
these were financial instruments that
enable the social exclusion of African
Americans and had precluded their
accumulation of private property through
exclusion from credit markets indeed the
politics of home ownership and the
desire for residents and non-segregated
or mixed-race neighborhoods continues to
structure the anxious everyday have a
socially mobile black bourgeoisie
meanwhile the african-american working
poor and the underclass would come to be
largely concentrated in the ghetto a
symbol of urban out casting a
consequence of the structured exclusion
of african-americans from the housing
market and what I think of as a kind of
incarcerated space of housing similar
processes were at work in Bombay too but
with rather different effects the
bubonic plague plague in Bombay 1896
have provided colonial administrators
with an alibi for demolishing vast
swathes of the Central City the plague
had also allowed planners and government
officials to undertake math expert mass
demolitions followed by experiments and
urban governance and industrial housing
on hygienic housing was raised in the
Bombay city Improvement Trust was
established to oversee construction of
poor and worker housing an important
experiment in public-private partnership
one that was rather extraordinary first
time was undertaken enabled by the use
of eminent domain for urban land
acquisition while money to purchase land
in working-class areas and by the
government was realized through the sale
of areas beyond the city's limit to
individual investors who land banked and
later used that land directly middle
class housing colonies in the interwar
period so that if you go north in Bombay
as anybody who's been there knows you
actually see the central part of the
city which is the kind of area labor
followed by middle-class housing and
then suburbs and so on it's ironic but
the immediate result of such social
engineering in Bombay the authoritarian
policy was housing scarcity more homes
were demolished and constructed after
the plague and Bombay never caught
most of you will know that over 60% of
Bombay's residents today are categorized
as living in slums
perhaps we can other self housing as a
1921 Industrial Disputes committee
observed the heaviest burden which labor
has to bear in Bombay arises from the
deficiency of housing accommodation and
the low quality of much that's available
rather than housing that incarcerated
the racial poor the ghetto or the
project as in the United States visual
Anarchy enabled by demographic density
and non-standardized construction self
housing the slum prevailed
thus efforts to control labor produce
distinctive infrastructures of
inequality in the interwar they produced
housing types and urban landscapes that
reproduced the logic of spatial
segregation with the during consequence
I'm suggesting here that the connection
between the problem of so-called Negro
housing and worker housing in Bombay is
a counterintuitive one it suggests
divergent outcomes for what was in
effect a global problematic urban
pacification in the context of
industrial unrest in the interwar urban
exclusion in North American cities was
produced by the right to housing as a
racialized right one that was
co-produced by the protection of private
property rights on the one hand and
complemented by corporal violence and
policing on the other meanwhile Bombay's
urban landscape was distinguished by
policies that actively produced housing
scarcity this generated practices of
self housing with the working poor
engaged in the production of informal
housing for themselves in the context of
government apathy the significant issue
here is that unlike the racial model of
incarcerated housing what we see here is
rough sleeping homelessness unhung
the episodic movement between formal and
informal housing and self housing that
is slum living as a response to state
policy since planning entails on
planning they exist in tension and
always generate something left over in
the process those remainder disposable I
which constitutes something like the
excess of planning now these connections
between India and the United States go
back earlier than the interwar of course
and they go back to the linkages of the
cotton Kingdom the section is called
social abstraction radical empiricism
cotton in his chapter 8 of the souls of
black folk entitled in the quest of the
Golden Fleece WB Dubois writes have you
ever seen a cotton field white with
harvest its golden fleece hovering above
the black earth like a silvery cloud
edged with dark green its bold white
signals waving like the foam of billows
from Carolina to Texas across that black
and human sea I've sometimes have
suspected that here the Wingard Ram
Chris Omelas left that fleece after
which Jason and his Argonauts went
vaguely wandering into the shadowy East
3,000 years ago and now the Golden
Fleece is found not only found but in
its birthplace woven for the hum of the
cotton mills is the newest and the most
significant thing in the new south today
as I've said earlier problems faced by
British industry in procuring cotton
from the American South during the Civil
War led to the opening of colonial
markets in Egypt in India which was
aided by steam shipping across the Suez
the rich vast black soil of the
conditioned Bera region was given over
to cotton while technologies for
rationalizing production and
accelerating the circulation of Bombay
cotton created new linkages between
rural hinterland in the city between
Bombay and the British Empire though the
end of the Civil War saw a sharp drop in
demand from global cotton there was
their dip in revenue demand even though
western India and southern India were
then also in the grip of drought and
famine these factors were directly
responsible for the infamous Deccan
riots of 1877 rural dispossession became
a major cause for migration to Bombay
which then was followed by the bubonic
plague that emptied out the city in 1896
the anti caste activist Jyoti ryofu lay
18
1790 describes this world in vivid
detail his attention to agrarian
distress as the combined outcome of
native rent-seeking and colonial surplus
extraction is remarkable so to his
sensitivity to peasants and forced
mobility and urban rural linkages that
structured structured the colonial
economy of the time he writes in the
past these farmers had very little land
and could not survive on its produce
they'd go into the nearby forest gather
wood fruit and leaves now if they want
to fill their bellies they have to work
in the factories as Weaver's iron
Smith's or carpenters or as casual
laborers in Ghulam Gary's slavery
dedicated to Abraham Lincoln and the
good people of the United States
Fuli notes that the Indian peasant and I
quote has in fact been a proverbial
Milch cow it was sufficient for their
purposes that they held him safe in
their clutches were squeezing out of him
as much as they possibly could
fuller goes on to link agrarian distress
with various states of transient and
impoverished existence and notes that
many farmers who can't subsist on their
fields any longer will leave home and
become vagrant wandering around and
working for wages in a big city instead
of starving foolish description DeLeon
delineates key aspects of the agrarian
sensorium the alienation for a labor
from its own labor power is detected in
foolish world by figures such as the
moneylender who indexed the
commodification of social relations in a
colonial economy his world writings
describe a world of routinized
deprivation with specific attention to
figures that embody vulnerability and
impoverishment his vignette about a day
in the life of a farmer merges an
account of deformed bodies with
depictions of a depleted unhygenic
environment the woman's clothes are in
tatters and they're forced forced to
wear ancient bedsheets bought for
marriage and under the Safa tree there
are a few children dancing half-naked
with all manner of staying stains on
their bodies noses running sweating and
stinking playing with lumps of mud
I'm gonna turn this off I think you've
got a sense of what this is okay a
putter or a poem written shortly after
by the president of the Bombay threesome
when she Mitra semaj which was a
reformist organization for Dalits in the
city written by one pundit condi rahm
ends with the powerful image of Mahajan
sitting on a dung heap
their bodies covered with ash sores on
their eyes rags covering their buttocks
their stomachs sunken and empty like for
this detailed description of the
cultivators life gone dear arms
attention to the wretched condition of
the Maharaj utilizes social description
what I've called radical empiricism as
the practice of eminent critique this is
the world that gyrus banaji also calls
up in his important study of the
commodification of agriculture in the
19th century Deccan a study that details
the subjugation of Indian small
peasantry to the usery capital of
morality and Gujarati merchants as well
as innocent capitalist class that was
emerging from the big peasantry in the
Deccan the argument here which is an
engagement with the logic of real and
formal sub sum is an argument that this
process would repurpose prior modes of
production so that they could perform in
a different historical environment but
nevertheless serve the requirements of
surplus extraction essentially vanadis
arguing peasant indebtedness to local
moneylenders had alienated them from the
means of production and it could be
argued that like the industrial
proletariat the peasant too was now
working for a wage agrarian indebtedness
rather than a sign of backwardness was
the historically specific mode by which
the peasant received a wage for his own
reproduction whether in the form of an
advance on crop to be delivered or as a
share of the crop in essence under
conditions of colonial capitalism then
peasant production for a global market
coupled with his reliance and Missouri's
loans for basic survival meant that the
peasant had in essence become dependent
on the capitalist and that he had
a worker we may also wish to recall
Dubois asan focus in the souls of black
folk on the debt economy he writes the
country is rich yet the people are poor
the keynote of the black belt is dead
not commercial credit but debt in the
sense of continued inability on the part
of the mass of the population to make
income cover expense this he argues is
the direct heritage of the south of the
wasteful economies of the slave regime
but that this was brought to crisis by
the emancipation of the slaves in his
discussion then of colonial capitalism
Bonacci engages for the specific forms
of abstraction to which capitalist
society gives rise but he is also alert
to the difference the difference here I
suggested to you is debt rather than
accumulation and when we think of social
abstraction of course we should think
about Marx's explanation of how the
commodity form comes to stand in for
social relations of exchange and product
exploitation so that a critique of
social life necessarily proceeds through
the critique of political economy when
anti caste thinkers like foo they
posited the relationship between
personhood and property and I just want
to draw your attention to these
remarkably
different yet simultaneous modes of
exploring this debt economy of the
deccan right around the same time one
thinking through what I've called
radical empiricism the the other really
engaging in a sense the arguments of
theoretical Marxism but with it albeit
with a difference so to come to Fuller
who posited the link between personhood
and property a relationship that was
crucial to the birth of modern
subjectivity we know that fully like
other anti cast thinkers does so
negatively for fronting degradation
humiliation impoverishment and
destitution as governing conditions of
social life for them caste in capital
like race and labor were mutually
entailed they produced new forms of
innumerous immiseration enabled
practices of predation and required new
practices of naming as description and
indeed as now
we could think here a foolish analysis
are the renaming of the Shudra atishoo
drew as an ethical collective that is
the collective of lower castes and
dilutes the repurposing of figures
associated with anti-castro teak for a
vernacular Marxism we're impoverished or
destitute bodies were named or called
out in their multiplicity and difference
we could think of the Ahram baker's
naming of the untouchable is dull it
ground down crushed broken versus
Gandhi's reclamation of the untouchable
is hydrogen or indeed WB Dubois this use
of the term of terms such as color cast
or abolition democracy terms which
conjugate a specific history against
normative political terms and concepts
and in a sense this harkens back to that
opening quote that I began with budget
Butler so these terms were enabled and
the renaming was enabled and the life
world's behind them made thinkable I
suggest through the paradoxical
proximity of Empire and emancipation
here race and labour or caste and labor
could appear as two sides of the same
coin
the one animating the other this
political economic approach saw the
intersection of economic exploitation in
historically contingent and evolving
forms and political domination which
reinforced and enabled labor
appropriation as mutually entailed basis
of racial injustice or caste injustice
and inequality so what so so I suggest
that you know so this this this part on
world is trying to create something like
the material conditions for the forms of
solidarity then that become thinkable
and imaginable so the section is called
caste race race caste solidarities I
just want to briefly go through a few
ways in which caste had appeared in the
discussions around race from the late
19th century as something that was
helpful for understanding what would
come to be called the aristocracy of
color
now caste had been present from the 19th
century in the work of abolition
who appear to have got it from
missionary discourse we see Frederick
Douglass William Lloyd Garrison
Sojourner Truth using the charm cast
Charles and we know Charles Sumner's
famous 1869 lecture on cast which was
delivered a year before the 15th
amendment to the US Constitution which
enfranchise black males using an
argument about the history of caste as a
way to understand u.s. racial hierarchy
viewing cast here as an artificial
discrimination born of impossible fable
one that was for ages the dominating
institution of ancient India Egypt
Persia Assyria and ancient Greek
societies Sumner art provides a detailed
description of the caste orders and
analogizes it with us racial hierarchy
he argues here the caste claiming
hereditary rank and privileges white the
caste doomed to hereditary degradation
and disability is black or yellow and
therefore the white man is superior is a
superior caste not unlike the Brahmin
while the black man is an inferior caste
not unlike shudra sometimes even the
pariah there is Katherine MPs
international journal called
anti caste which was published between
1888 to 1893 and again in 1895 which we
published and excerpted articles and
speeches from newspapers from on other
places the u.s. England and India and
I'm drawing some of this from the work
of demetrius Udell and udel draws her
attention to the fact that impe modeled
her journal on Booker T Washington's
more moderate publication the southern
letter and of course Booker T Washington
and experiments with vocational
education are really profoundly
important it is something that Gandhi
for instance is aware of and so on and
so forth and so there's kind of global
spread of many of these experiments and
then we can come to robert park a
central figure in the den emergent field
of sociology at the university of
chicago connecting back with the chicago
i knew
who uses cast as a prism to understand
race relations in the US while this
paradigm was adopted by some scholars
ironically in Myrtle's highly
influential the American dilemma the
Negro problem and modern democracy we
see others such as the Caribbean
sociologist our Oliver chromic Cromwell
Cox who also trained at the Chicago
school of sociology rejecting what he
identified as the caste school of race
relations and in his caste class and
race of 1948 he argues that what Myrtle
and others do is to reduce the systemic
character of white supremacy to a moral
dilemma thesis the notion that the
American Negro problem is a problem in a
sense which is in the heart or which is
a kind of moral problem for white
America and and this would be something
that you know is an argument that gets
picked up
Cox's argument gets picked up well after
his time and it gets picked up in the
1960s in the systemic structural and
institutional analyses of racism with
many people picking up I think on two
key terms one is the notion of internal
colonization or colonialism which is a
term that's used to think about race and
racial difference in racial
stigmatization in the United States and
the second of course is just the term
institutional racism itself we can also
think I think I think about historians
George Frederickson being the most I
think famous who writes in white
supremacy about connections between the
United States and South Africa and again
the argument here being an argument
about racial supremacy or white
supremacy which is explicitly the model
that Frederickson uses to connect these
spaces and I could draw attention to a
few other productions of the caste
school of race relations there's a Lloyd
Warner's American cast in class
published in 1936 Bob Gallagher's
American cast in the Negro College
published in 1938 John dollard's famous
text cast in class in a southern town
written in 1937
Lloyd Warner and Alison Davis's critique
of dollar in a comparative study of
American cast where they draw on people
like Google a cenar & risley Herbert
Risley to argue that flat that cast
actually exhibit exhibits much greater
fluidity and regional variety than folks
in this cast school of racial relations
actually allow for and then a text
called children of bondage a study of
educational exclusion by David B Dollard
which was published just as a research
for myrtles - vol 1500 page American
dilemma which was funded by the Carnegie
Corporation was coming to an end and
then there was the very important
ethnography which was published in 1941
deep south which was supervised by Lloyd
Warner and researched by Allison Davis
his wife Elizabeth and the Gardiners
bits of which Myrtle cites there's
another kind of storyline here - about
the Dunning school the famous or
infamous school of history at Columbia
University which also is behind a
production of some of the work that I've
been talking about but I'm happy to talk
about this later but I just want to
mention that during the 1940s when these
publications are coming out Ambedkar
writes a letter as we know because I
this is a quite famous you know
historical fact tidbit that Ambedkar
writes a letter in 1946 to Dubois
requesting copies of a petition that
ambe Dubois had submitted to the United
Nations by black Americans identifying
himself as a student of the Negro
problem who belonged to the Untouchables
of America India Ambedkar asserts that
there was so much similarity between the
position of Untouchables in India and
the position of Negroes in America that
the study of the latter is not only
natural but necessary
Dubois as we know confirms that the
National Negro Congress a small
organization had drafted this statement
and that he expected the n-double-a-cp
to submit a more comprehensive statement
we also know that the UN didn't consider
it
statement and that this really went
nowhere Dubois had mentioned had had
maintained that between 1910 and 1930 he
had revolutionized he argues the
American Negroes attitude to caste he
writes in Seoul's already in 1903 of
social caste of caste as a barrier in
his 1909 evolution of the race problem
he's already speaking about color cast
as structuring both slavery and its
aftermath color caste he argues was
entrenched through the process of
treating free blacks as if they were
slaves and I quote the caste of color
was turned as to correspond with the
caste of work and enslave not only
slaves but black men who were not slaves
Dubois noted however that the free Negro
had hastened the economic crisis which
killed slavery and had made it
impossible to make the caste of work and
the caste of color correspond he was he
argues the promise and the cause of
those who forced the critical revolution
it might be good to tarry a while with
Dubois and his idea of the Negro as that
peculiar agent of historical
transformation his analysis has bowed
deeper and more profound than the very
best scholarship that had been produced
under the sky under the sign of the
caste school of race relations this it
seems to me is because he asks the
unanswerable question of origins and
because he wants to think of this
peculiar historical agent the Negro as a
problem for thought as named Chandler
has argued and has important text X but
in the interest of time it might be
worth noting the distinctive use of the
term caste
in all of these works one that appears
to have seen caste as a way to address
the overlapping structures of repulsion
discrimination exclusion and inequality
Dubois was most clear perhaps again here
that what was really at issue in
thinking about colorcast was the social
heritage of slavery
and inheritance sir should be clear
already the comparisons also went the
other way across the 20th century anti
caste thinkers related struggles for
caste quality with global movements for
human emancipation
if Indian nationalists and social
performers had provincial eyes cast as
an intensely local form of hierarchy
antique as thinkers would already draw
on historical comparison between caste
and other forms of inequality this
problem has continued into scholarly
production if Western Theory has tended
to treat caste as a form of
non-political difference and a
manifestation of hierarchy that
contrasts with North Atlantic
conceptions of equality scholars of
South Asia have responded by
historicizing castes social pertinence
and its analytic centrality but their
efforts have also had the ironic effect
of rendering cast into sub-continental
difference we know for instance that Joe
Terra who they draw on the model of
Atlantic world slavery of white and
black to mark a historic conflict and a
primary contradiction between Brahman
and non brahmana between intellectual
and manual labor
and between Aryan invaders versus
autochthonous people's Ambedkar
constitutional lawyer thinker and
theorist of radical equality compared
the untouchables position negatively
with that of the slave who was engaged
at least he argued in value producing
labor other pertinent comparisons also
followed with minority populations who
were the detritus of Imperial breakdown
and reorganization such as the Chu but I
also want so I'm I want to stop for a
second and suggest first that we should
be careful of such comparison but also
that it's possible that in the context
of race biology 'some on the one hand
and the discourse of class and
exploitation as a primary way to
understand inequality on the other that
caste might have offered more to
thinkers of race than perhaps the other
way around
Ambedkar was clear lid in his life for
instance that caste and race could not
be compared
that commenced raishin actually pointed
to its limits while opening the field of
adjacencies and proximities we seen two
boys doing something similar in his
writings on the plight of the jews when
he visits Germany in 1936 and notes that
while there are echoes or resonances of
the plight of the Jew and the negro they
cannot be reduced or rendered equivalent
under National Socialism and Jim Crow
respectively indeed by the mid-to-late
1930s National Socialism coming back to
our global frame and thinking about
Imperial breakdown and transformation
National Socialism coupled with changes
in the philosophy and strategy of
commerce nationalism in India and the
practice of Gandhian ISM created real
resistance to thinking caste through
race and by the 1940s and Baker's many
experiments he had utilised the colonial
mechanisms for producing parity between
communities he had sought occasional
alliance with Communists he had been
inspired by the legislation of race a
civic disability in understanding the
social exclusions of caste and in his
thinking of caste boycott as the
enforcement of what he would call
illegal law and in that sense drawing on
the kind of American history of the
legal legislation of race and he had
formed solidarities with the Muslim
minority in each of these he would feel
by the 1940s had ended in some kind of
betrayal Ambedkar texts thoughts on
Pakistan written in 1941 and Pakistan or
the partition of India and 45 marks the
culmination of his reflections on the
linked fate of the little Muslims as non
Hindu minorities and his simultaneous
awareness of their histories and
difference shaped by the problem of
sovereignty in the second edition of
this Pakistan or the partition of India
published in 45 Ambedkar by his own
admission underscores the singular
nature of his enterprise and indeed the
fact that it had fallen on deaf ears by
noting that this was a book that was
disowned by Hindus and fine owned by the
Muslims and that this had only
emboldened his own claim
non-partisanship in order to think in a
sense non ideologically if you will
about the question of Pakistan and I
think one really should think about
Ambedkar is one of the first
philosophers of the idea of Pakistan he
traces the transformation of Muslim
demands from minority protection within
the nation to their arguments for a
separate nation dispassionately noting
that while majority and minority existed
as entities within the nation the nation
form itself was organized around
effective bonds and the feeling of
commonality and indeed the two texts on
Pakistan recognized and I think quite
dispassionately that what the Muslim
what Muslims in India had managed to do
was indeed to think about nationality
through the through these effective
bonds of commonality and there is there
also I suppose morning the impossibility
of being able to do so for the le'ts as
well this is also an important global
moment going back just a little bit to
the 30s and the 40s and I want to
suggest that if we see the matured voice
embracing communism in this time think
of that magnum opus black reconstruction
then Ambedkar's writings after 1935 and
36 after his magnum opus annihilation of
caste published in 36 charts a path
towards his eventual but this conversion
and so even as in a sense you know
Dubois in the 30s and Beyond is kind of
moving out into the world and really
taking up the arguments that he's been
making from the early teens about
thinking through the question of the
global color line of thinking about
color cast and Empire we see it seems to
me a baker beginning to kind of move
inwards and moving in his late writings
towards the question of history and
towards the question of Buddhism so
black reconstruction signaled a turning
point to Dubois as thinking so did the
annihilation of caste mark this turning
point to texts published within a year
you know and what unites these otherwise
disparate texts is their authors
discovery of the logic governing so
so order race and Hinduism respectively
Dubois had preferred to the hardening of
the caste system when he associated the
failure of emancipation with the rise of
racial capitalism and the emergence of
white and black proletariat the
annihilation of caste posited
intractability of untouchability reform
when conceived within Gandhi and rubrics
have been emphasized Hinduism capable of
doing justice to the untouchable
triggered by Gandhi's hydrogen in the
extended debate with Gandhi that has
text inaugurated Ambedkar argued that
the abolition of caste was impossible
without annihilating Hinduism since
caste and Hinduism were mutually
entailed as earlier efforts to specify
the Civic disability of caste gave way
to a concern with the past in a baker's
late writing he began to argue that the
Dalit was a subject of historical
violence a form of remaindered life
produced by the epochal conflict between
Buddhism and Brahmanism the outcast was
the excluded insider Simon
simultaneously within and without Hindu
society one which was organized around
an original line between the touchable
and the untouchables in his late
writings on the history of caste and
untouchability as well as in a text
written in 1954 which was titled
revolution and counter-revolution in
ancient India Ambedkar analyzes
brahmanism as a form of rule and as a
practice of sovereignty he argues there
that reactionary casteist forces and
vanquished a vibrant egalitarian world
of Buddhism by killing the Buddhist King
pushyamitra 185 BCE
unlike Islam which was more recent
unbreakable argued and which was framed
as a matter of competitive sovereignty
between Hindus and Muslims both have
been rulers caste relationship to
brahmanism and Brahmanism intimacy but
state power was ancient pervasive but
also forgotten and it's here that
Ambedkar writes that the history of
India is nothing but a history of mortal
conflict between Buddhism and Brahmanism
I'll just make a quick detour or a segue
from this this 1954 text revolution and
counter-revolution reminds us of a text
that Ambedkar would argue stayed with
him throughout his life and this is his
1916 text castes in India their
mechanisms Genesis and development and
this text caste in India 1916 written
while he was at Columbia does something
quite interesting and it goes back to
this question of the conversation
between caste and race because they're
drawing on Weber Ambedkar will make
first the arguments that caste is an
enclosed class and therefore it's very
difficult to actually think through what
makes castes specific and second he says
that if there is a logic of
differentiation that organizes race and
caste then it's quite interesting to
think about their difference all right
race endogamy the fact that there is no
miscegenation across the color line is
the consequence he will argue of racial
segregation but in India and this is
something that he holds throughout his
life which makes it difficult for him to
embrace foolish argument for instance of
a kind of historical racial conflict
between Brahmins and non-brahmins but in
the context of caste Ambedkar will argue
caste exists despite a kind of racial or
national amalgamation he resists
strongly the idea that different castes
are racially distinct so this poses a
very particular question for him to
explain what it is that actually
produces caste as such and what creates
differences between castes right the
idea that castes cannot intermarry do
not practice intimacy in social
intercourse and it's here then that
Ambedkar actually draws on the
relationship between sexual order and
the primacy of the sexual ordering of
caste as a way to think about its social
reproduction and he will argue that
there is a complex relationship between
endogamy and exogamy
in the way that castes are organized and
that there was actually a question of
how to practice endogamy how to make
sure that casa
she didn't relate with each other
through especially through sexual
intimacy and it's here that he goes
towards an argument about gender and
gender signification by arguing that the
structuring of this order had to do with
the ways in which the caste economy the
economy of caste actually deals with
surplus men and surplus women right and
at what we have and this is a
statistical argument and it's an
argument also about the violence of
caste right that actually even as child
marriage was a way to deal with the
question of surplus men surplus women
were merely killed off right and
therefore the practice of sati and so on
and so forth and so this becomes very
interesting because what Ambedkar seems
then to be arguing is not so much that
sex or sexuality is prior but that caste
is prior and that it is caste that gives
to gender it's kind of social pertinence
but perhaps also its legibility
but anyway be that as it may I just
wanted to sort of go off on this detour
that it's it's interesting to think
about the moments when Ambedkar is
actually trying to think
comparatively if you will or in a
connected fashion about race and caste
and the places where he else also
rejects this right he rejects this late
in life but then we could go back and
look at Cass in India also as trying to
distinguish the specificity of caste
from race so to return to this 1954 text
as I've said you know he discovers here
a kind of you know millennial egg on
right the relationship between
brahminism and Buddhism as he argues is
actually structuring Indian history to
core so his conversion when it happens
in 1956 was meant to activate the
historical memory of Buddhism's
disappearance in the land of its birth
Buddhism Ambedkar had begun to argue
with coeval and status with Hinduism but
superior to it in form and substance its
absence in India was actually proof of
Brahman isms dominance but Buddhism was
an Indian whose authority no one could
challenge since it preceded the
establishment of organized
piranhas Hinduism it's very interesting
that that Ambedkar and I think many
others sub-continental thinkers are
really thinking about Buddhism and Islam
and you know Hinduism appears almost as
a kind of secondary space but they're
really thinking to a discussion of
Buddhism and Islam as animating and
structuring its relationship to to
Hinduism and that that's the space that
we actually need to be thinking about
but in any case the epistemic space then
that Ambedkar had claimed troupe of this
conversion was ingenious and
unassailable
but the Nirvana or the new vehicle
Buddhism that he established was an
effect a godless religion not legible to
extant traditions a mid-course
conversion then did not only offer an
escape from Hinduism but it also
underscored the singular circumstance of
his response for what Ambedkar managed
to do was to restage caste difference as
a religious difference buddhism versus
Brahmanism that was both familiar and
new a conversation that one assumed had
already occurred in the millennial past
but the contents of which were in fact
to be decided in the future to come I
don't really have an ending but to end
here I think I would go back in a sense
to that to that opening quote by Judith
Butler which makes a an argument about a
kind of radical claim on the universal
and poses this question if you know what
happens when we think the universal from
the space of the contaminated subject
right the minority subject who is
differently minoritized and the
circumstances affect minorities ation
I'm trying to suggest being both
historically specific but also it seems
to me commensurable but within limits
and so I'll leave in a sense with this
problem of the minority subject and her
question to us in the 20th and the 21st
century which is about how to relate
this question of embodiment
and the universal and how to activate
that relationship it seems to me a new
under any given set of circumstances or
conjunctures so that the billet then
becomes we could also say good to think
right and it's possible that somebody
else stands in the place of so as we
were talking about sexual minorities and
so on it's possible that someone else
stands in the place of this particular
political subject and so we could read
this I suppose both as a historically
specific argument but also perhaps as an
argument that is good to think with in
terms of where we want to go in
activating precisely this kind of
problematic I'll stop there absolutely
yeah I'd love to
I mean so you know I mean there's
there's supposed to ways or one could
respond to this from two ends as it were
right so one would be if you know one is
to think from the perspective of
precisely those groups that you're
talking about then it calls up a
particular history where we would have
to say well what are we doing in some
very real sense what do we do with the
question of indenture what do we do with
the way in which indenture becomes a
kind of intermediary moment if you will
if you wanted things for on the one hand
the question of slavery slavery both as
kind of metaphors right in Fuli and so
on real Atlantic world Plantation
slavery on the one hand and then the
question of freedom and equality right
so we're in that kind of continuum would
you place something like indenture and
real historical time if I can put it
that way and then you really do have to
think through it seems to me those
spaces you have to
through the Caribbean you need to think
through South Africa you need to think
through the very particular ways in
which for instance the question of you
know Indians and Africans and so on
really gets figured and there it seems
to me the question becomes quite it's a
difficult one I mean it's I'm not
somebody who is an expert on those
spaces but I would say that you know it
becomes a very difficult one because the
kinds of forgetting then that are called
that are required and then the other
modes of acknowledgement really are
transformed right and so there perhaps
you know there is there is real
proximity there's real intimacy it
produces something quite distinctive it
produces new family forms and your
family formations and then maybe some
some bit of the question that you're
asking about contamination and so on
gets relocated to some you know odd
notion of a kind of domestic interior
its relationship to homeland and so on
I'm just speculating but but it seems to
me that you know that would be one way
to think through discretion of
contamination but if you know from the
other end of things I mean you're sort
of asking how broadly can we think the
question of a kind of ritual
contamination one that's not about
stigmatize or degraded labor and so on
that's what I'm understanding and and
how much does that do you know how much
does that travel the immediate response
I suppose would be to say no but then it
seems to me that you know you also want
to think about sort of orders of
repulsion and orders of objection and it
doesn't have to be a kind of ritual
notion of contamination where at some
level if you think about it the Brahman
is as untouchable as as the untouchable
right this is the kind of argument for
instance that Gopal guru and Sanders are
okay and so forth make and really
capitalize on and mirror that you know
there is a kind of order where
untouchability can be episodic and
transient and then there is a permanent
outcasting and Victor is also quite
clued in to all of this so there i
suppose the question is is is almost
about sort of the body and different
ways
which questions of repulsion objection
stigma relates to the body and it seems
to think a little bit more comparatively
or maybe at least imaginatively to think
through you know different ways of
parsing that but again you know I mean
this is sort of off off the top of my
head in thinking about in thinking about
this but it seems to me that we
shouldn't sort of restrict ourselves to
thinking about contamination in the way
that you're asking about it it in hears
it
it is replayed it seems to me or it's it
gets remembered and things like cast
violins archaic forms of violence right
where you have cast violence that is
both profoundly modern but is always
harking back to notions of the body
it's dismemberment where the body
belongs what kinds of spaces it should
be in so many of the kind of the
repertoire is if you will have cast
violence also end up remarking through
the mutilated body of the Linton's own
kettle Angie did this very explicitly
right it actually remakes the boundaries
as it were for village order and new
foreign and forms of sociality in and
through the dismembered body of men and
women and and so that kind of a
significant I suppose does require
reading and reading specifically but we
could also it seems to me things through
family resemblances rather than
comparison or direct you know analogies
but maybe at least sort of family
resemblances things calling us things
lynching right and so on and so forth
and to that extent its ritual to that
extent it's about contamination but
about very specific historical orders as
well
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
sure I mean this is a this is a really
rich question so thank you for that I'll
try to do justice to at least maybe some
portion of it and then let me know if if
you know there are other bits of it
because there's sort of two parts to the
question that you asked one you know
about the relationship between caste and
Hinduism very differently imagined of
course by Ambedkar and Gandhi and then
the second is about comparative religion
I'm very excited about the comparative
religion part of your questions so I
want to try to set up answer that by
elaborating on this on this issue of
Buddhism right because I think
absolutely people are reading
comparative religion but the other thing
to also think about I mean Ambedkar is a
person in his time even if his thought
kind of exceeds it and so one of the
things that we're seeing for instance
with the with the argument about
Buddhism is the extent to which you know
there are kind of two maybe even three
different strains of what's happening
with the rediscovery of Buddhism at this
time one is coming and Ambedkar is not
part of this but one is really coming
from from from the South from the tamil
country and a very long tradition
especially of the Puryear community and
their relationship to histories of
Jainism and Buddhism so we should
remember that you know Ambedkar sort of
writes the foreword to Lakshmi notices
essence of Buddhism and luxury Nasser
himself is part of a long tradition of
thummell Dalit Buddhism right and that's
the kind of you know and that's a
different kind of a genealogy right but
you know but then there's something else
that's also happening which is the ways
in which coming back to comparative
religion one would be to think
comparatively about Hinduism the
argument about monotheism many gods you
know but you know one one kind of
substance or essence and so on but the
fact that you know at the very same time
that we're having that kind of a
conversation and comparative religion
about Hinduism we've also got the
rediscovery of Buddhism all right and so
in many ways I'm bakers
argument about the Buddhist homeland as
the kind of unavailable space for
Buddhism right so Buddhism is is here
there are signs of it but it no longer
exists and you know Ambedkar does this
by going back and trying to argue that
the Dalit actually is the kind of
remaindered subject and the enduring
remnant and reminder for kind of
Buddhism that had been vanquished and he
connects that with an argument about the
cow and about beef and very interesting
thinking about what's happening today
with with lynchings and so on and so so
you know there is there's that kind of
an argument that he makes but the other
in terms of the rediscovery of Buddhism
is people like dharmapala and a Gurkha
dharmapala
but also people like sankrityayan vermin
and Kosambi right Dee Dee's father who
converts sankiji ayam is a Buddhist and
then becomes a Marxist and so you've got
sort of you know people who are also on
a very different search for what I would
call you know I mean if you can think
about a kind of Islamic universality
speaking about that period khilafat even
the argument about the subcontinent as
v-space for Islam you know new
scholarship shab Emmas etc but also the
argument that people like Iqbal and
others are making we're seeing an
argument about Buddhism also as that
kind of a universality yet with a
different notion of its geographical
spread that's why I said you know Islam
Buddhism become very interesting to
think about in terms of our conversation
about Hinduism so all of this is
happening and it's kind of you know it's
it's it's the predecessor if you will
for what Ambedkar is doing and so what
I'm what i think briefly i would just
want to suggest is that you know it's
not that Ambedkar is not picking up on
some of these arguments about you know
Edwin Arnold's you know light on Asia
the rediscovery of Buddhism as a counter
even to Hinduism where that argument
about Buddhism as a kind of civic
religion goes many people are doing this
Baker comes to this with his own special
kind of twist very much like you know
I've tried to argue that Dubois is also
swimming in the waters of you know the
caste school of race relations and so on
but he does something
is quite extraordinary and distinctive
and perhaps that's why we want to think
of these people as political
philosophers political thinkers you know
but I'll put myself around I'd rather
win by saying that so I think there is
that world that Ambedkar is kind of
channeling and receiving but he's doing
something he's taking it somewhere else
so I hope that answers your question
about comparative religion and there's
lots to say there's lots more to say I
mean there's alma Paulo and I mean in a
way the kind of cleansing of a kind of
Buddhism that happens through the maha
bodhi society right because the maha
bodhi society is in sri lanka they moved
to calcutta and so on and then the other
kind of cleansing that's happening is
through people like Tsuzuki and others
right where they wanted to actually
think about Buddhism as philosophy and
they want to do away with the whole
history of Buddhist religiosity popular
religiosity so I think there's something
quite interesting that that's going on
and I think one should be critical in
that sense of the kind of minimal
Buddhism that Ambedkar also produces it
seems to me it's part and parcel of
those kinds of practices as much as it
is the reading of Nirvana Buddhism and a
new history of the Dalit so you know I'd
sort of leave that there your other
question about sort of caste and
Hinduism and Gandhi and I'm basically I
mean what to say yes caste must go and
and Hinduism cannot cannot be redeemed I
mean this would be it seems to me I'm
Baker's argument but that argument about
you know sort of caste anihilation I
mean if I would put this in a slightly
different way I think that that move of
um breakers after the 32 conversation
and the conflict with Gandhi is actually
a response to a question that Gandhi
poses that he can't answer because I
think Gandhi actually poses the question
I mean he essentially says you know what
what is it that you want right and can
you actually operate in a purely kind of
political space if you will without the
notion of a kind of
is religion if you will practice this
[ __ ] well you know I don't know what
you want to call it and I think on
deposes that was a profound question and
it produces a kind of dilemma it seems
to me from bed good and he has to answer
that question in the way that he will
which is the angry insurgent incredibly
logical sort of extraordinary response
that he produces in 36 with the
annihilation of caste but I don't know
if it's a it's a question that is that
is kind of resolved I mean one loves the
argument about caste annihilation and
the annihilation of Hinduism what is
front to it I suppose
both kind of politically and
philosophically in some sense but you
know the kind of deeper integuments you
know in terms of the conversation either
with Gandhi or quote/unquote Hinduism or
where is Buddhism here I think it's a
little bit more open but I don't know if
that that responds to yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that is the kind of post a big question
you're asking yeah these to me
it's person right right yeah sure sure
no and I think you know I mean and the
important question in a sense that
you're asking also because when we
talked about this earlier today that you
know some of this work is kind of
thinking about thought in its non
relation as it were to the question of
the state right and and so I think your
question in a sense of you know what
might be other ways to think about this
becomes a question in the 40s and the
50s about policy design and it becomes a
question of the relationship between
state and minority right that final text
of our Baker's as well on staking
minorities and so I think there the
question of kind of you know remediation
if you will is not this kind of a
project which is you know imagining a
kind of political future that is
experimental that is interruptive that
is kind of profoundly insurgent if you
you know whatever term you want but it's
really thinking through the question of
actual social entitlements and the
question of the state and then I think
it becomes very difficult to say I mean
I've always maintained the colonial
genealogy because it seems to me that
there you can go from the 1880s onwards
and you know whenever I teach I'm always
telling people well you know it's a
century before 1965 that India is
actually dealing with the question of
reservations but the question of
reservations of course in India is a
complicated one because it becomes a
question of proportional representation
not of minority representation and then
it has to move towards represents as we
know it with you know the sheduled caste
becoming the model subject but then kind
of you know everything moving out and
developing out from that project also in
the Constitution but we could suppose
think I mean one way and this was the
way that to me
which I like would be to think about the
kind of colonial genealogy if we're
thinking about kind of colonial
genealogies of thought it seems to me we
could also think about colonial
genealogies of sort of political
instruments right so the ethnic
electorate the separate electorate
reservations the question of mandate the
question that gets posed of to nation
one territory I mean all of these are
experiments that are a profound
challenge to the question of empire
nation that we inherit in terms of the
European genealogy of the state right in
state form into the 20th century and
beyond so that part of it I suppose one
could one could argue Ambedkar is
beginning to do this but then you have a
very interesting problematic so you see
him for instance in the start committee
and so on and he'll have these
conversations about the caste boycott
but then when he makes an argument about
boycott and class boycott the terms that
he is using could be Plessy versus from
you know so then it's the argument about
public public amenities and public
access and then you select okay yes we
know you were sitting in the United
States you know did that come from them
so I think that vice versa I think it is
very hard to kind of figure out where
those may be where some of those
histories lie and and it seems to me I
mean just kind of is a simple response
that much more needs to be done on
actually the way in which the question
of public amenities develops out of a
common law tradition right or kind of
British common law tradition and that
that it seems to me is actually where we
can begin to see something have a kind
of early sense of civic disabilities
Civic redress remediation and then that
gets kind of worth large and I mean it
can say far better than I it seems to me
that that then gets you know written out
and expanded and elaborated in the 40s
and the 50s but but yeah I mean there
would be that there's I think there's
also I mean there's an interesting and
weird way in which we've not thought
about other spaces you know we've not
thought of something like you know
Malaysia we don't think about South
Africa you know we don't think about
again all of those experiments
happening 30s 40s 50s and beyond and and
the extent to which in a sense South
Africa is both the kind of pariah state
you know belated you know the entire
world is decolonizing and they're
instituting apartheid but surely there
there's an interesting genealogy of
ethnic electorate to be followed up to
right so so yeah I mean I think I mean
you know I think your your question in
in a sense to circle back to what I said
that this question of the state is one
that I think we do have to think about
you know and Baedeker is not you know
it's a neither does he want to
annihilate the state he wants to
annihilate caste but not the state and
neither does he in a sense not want to
tarry with the state and so that problem
in a sense of the 40s and the 50s I
think is also the foreclosure of the
earlier openings and it goes back to his
thinking well Muslims and ballads
you know we create solidarity oh maybe
there's some other way for me to parse
this in a colonial Imperial frame but I
have other allies outside of the
subcontinent and all of those things
actually become impossible and he has to
transact with the state in the way that
you're asking
[Music]
[Music]
sure no and I mean in a sense this goes
back or it has a lot of resonance I
think also with the question that maybe
Rohit was asking right look I mean it's
it's a little difficult for me I mean
you know because I do on bitkha and then
you know I know I know
in a sense engage african-american
political thought
so to think about kind of you know deep
provincial izing race right and in a
sense removing it from this very
particular history that we have of a
kind of Atlantic world formation and so
on and so forth does become really
difficult as I've said Ambedkar himself
is a is a thinker of his time as well as
as much as he is sort of outside of it
and I think you know whether you were
thinking about the way that he's using
colonial photography or that very
interesting way in which he's trying to
think through the question of slavery
and caste there's a kind of there's
there's a lack of flexibility I suppose
there's a lack of historian right we
know he's talking about Aptheker and so
on but it's not as if he is really
thinking in that sense about a kind of
full-blown comparison I think the it's
also strategic because it allows him to
do certain things
so I don't know if you know it I don't
know if America becomes the person in
some sense through whom we want to think
about whether there's a more expansive
notion as it were thinking the race
question I mean it actually might be
more interesting to think about someone
like Vidya right and you know his many
peregrinations I mean he is a global
subject too we've not really talked
about this but you know there's an
interesting way in which and also
because for him you know the question is
kind of social life in the domain of
what we might think of now as kind of
civil society is the place that is most
interesting and important for him you
could think about somebody like that
maybe even someone like Gandhi who has a
more interesting and expansive notion
perhaps of the way that race is
operating certainly in the first part of
his life because he is a South African
thinker as much as he is an Indian one
it seems to me so to that extent I guess
you know I hear what you're saying one
could be critical I suppose a from bit
good if you were to say what are what is
a more globally ramified or more
socially complete yeah yeah or a more
socially kind of you know complex and
complete way to think about it I really
would come back to I think also this
question of indenture that you know if
we think of a certain kind of counter
global history that thinks through
slavery and dehumanization then that
logic of and we're thinking about a kind
of colonial capital the logic of
colonial capitalism or imperial capital
and so on then I think we might have to
think about the actual other spaces that
are really you know within the field of
a more expansive way of thinking race
and again race perhaps in the way that
someone like Foucault will suggest it
right it's it's a it's a it's a form of
kind of repulsion it's a form of
differentiation in x marks the spot
it can be gendered it can be truly from
it can be about chromatids 'm as it were
it can be about ritual practices it can
be about other orders of ecstasy as
opposed to intimacy but that one could
think
also a racism in that sense as a
constantly activated form of
differentiation and you can cut that
social fabric any which way you will so
two ways to think it right one through a
kind of historically more expansive way
of thinking race racism in the nineteen
twenty eight century and maybe in terms
of a kind of political philosophy
thinking racism right as a kind of
engagement between or the paradoxical
engagement between equality and
difference right the dialectic and that
racism becomes in that sense a kind of
almost a kind of necessary outgrowth of
that I heard that machine that identity
difference kind of machine if you will
or a quality difference machine thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]